[Musique]
diplôme d'ingénieur en poche j'ai
commencé à travailler pour des grandes
entreprises est en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est que après quelques années de
pérégrinations j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser aux ressources et notamment
à l'une d'entre elles
l'énergie et comme pour tout bon
ingénieur l'énergie c'est tout sauf une
pensée ésotérique qui se diffuse comme
ça des uns vers les autres
l'énergie c'est hyper concret l'énergie
ça malaxe sator sans rediffusé ça fait
tourner l'économie est en fait quand on
maîtrise un peu la règle de trois et
quand on s'aperçoit que quand on regarde
un peu la quantité la production
d'énergie mondiale la corrélation quasi
exacte qui a entre l'énergie mondiale et
la croissance du pib et quand on regarde
les limites actuelles limites
environnementales climatique et les
limites de notre technique actuelle on
se dit ça risque de pas passer
et moi quand j'ai compris ça je me suis
dit je suis partie tambour battant
décroissance sobriété volontaire c'était
forcément ça à la solution et les autres
qu'est ce qu'ils font la société qu'est
ce qu'elle fait elle est dans le déni
elle fait l'autruche on veut pas voir le
problème on veut pas réaliser que si on
ne tient pas compte de ces limites
toujours criantes tous les jours plus
prégnante
on risque de s'effondrer lamentablement
on risque de finir comme les types de
l'île de pâques et peut-être que dans
des millions d'années il y aura des
archéologues d'une autre espèce qui dans
au milieu d'un site de fouilles se dire
ans mais qu'est ce que c'est ce
suppositoire géant au milieu d'une
mégalopole
et mais moi j'étais
d'idéation à josy ans à faire du
marketing de la vie simple on va essayer
de se motiver et on a essayé de ne plus
avoir envie de téléphone toutes les deux
semaines avant que la société ne puisse
plus nous fournir des téléphones toutes
les deux semaines
on va essayer d'avoir envie d'une
société plus sobre
avant qu'on n'ait plus les moyens
d'avoir une société énergivore et
croissance ou faux croissance auv or tel
qu'on l'a aujourd'hui est en fait c'est
vraiment possible
je me suis dit c'est un peu comme quand
je m'approche de ma nièce à noël et que
j'essaie de lui chiper son camion de
pompiers est là honnêtement si vous
tentez de faire ça vous allez voir vous
risquez d'y perdre endroit parce que
sébastien là c'est hyper vorace annuels
et alors peut-être que vous vous tenez
pas à votre bras mais honnêtement si
vous voulez éviter les geignements les
pleurs les crises mais il suffit d'y
aller deux jours plus tard est dupliqué
à ce moment là et en fait vous rendrez
compte que c'est peut-être cette
différence est un esprit qui peut nous
sauver
peut-être que si on fait du marketing de
la vie simple et qu'on n'a plus envie
des joujoux nos joujoux avant qu'on ait
plus les moyens de le produire
eh bien ça fera que cette transition se
fera de manière plus agréable et c'est
ça ce marketing de l'asic fille simple
j'y croyais très très fort parce que le
marketing ça par nos émotions et les
mots émotion c'est le moteur le plus
puissant de nos actions
et puis quand même j'ai écumé le net
j'écume et internet à la recherche de
ressources documentaires qui allait me
conforter dans ma vision du monde et
malgré ma volonté de me conforter j'ai
quand même trouvé des sources qui
étaient en désaccord fondamental est ce
que je pensais et c'est sûr je ne
pouvais pas les accuser de ne pas avoir
conscience des mêmes enjeux que moi en
fait il ya des gens qui partent du même
constamment mais en fait il avait
d'autres options
d'autres alternatives et enfin car
regardé sincèrement il ya trois
scénarios auxquels les gens croient pour
demain le premier scénario celui dont je
faisais que dont je vous ai parlé
le scénario d'une décroissance maîtrisé
après le deuxième scénario le seigneur
des gens qui pensent que ben non
l'effondrement est inévitable on est
allé trop loin
parmi eux il ya un mec très sérieux
français qui a écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelle commande tout peut s'effondrer
et que vous arrivez à la fin du bouquin
vous apercevez qu'en fait c'était pas
une éventualité son titre et remet la
troisième catégorie c les gens qui
croient mordicus qu une continuité de la
croissance humaine une continuité de la
complexité est possible qu'on va arriver
à se sortir de l'ornière par un miracle
technologique et parmi ceux là il ya
vraiment des gens hyper intéressant
notamment deux chaînes youtube de
vulgarisation scientifique y sont très
très fortes crash causé courte exact
après vous avez un blog fascinant
d'intelligence qui s'appelle wade
boutoille et enfin vous avez un monsieur
qui veut tout simplement envoyer un
million de personnes sur mars
et honnêtement j'ai bon ben c'est hyper
intelligent je pense pas jouer ma vie
sur un concours d'indigence avec le losc
et en fait il ya une vidéo de crash
course moi qui m'a fait me rendre compte
de quelque chose tu m'as fait de rendre
compte que quand on dit croire à un
scénario ça veut bien dire ce que ça
veut dire à un moment dans une certaine
mesure les scénarios dont je viens de
parler ils sont basés sur une croyance
la croyance ma croyance des décroissants
c'est que quelque part il faut
absolument avoir un principe de
précaution
il faut pas vendre la peau de l'ours
avant de l'avoir tué il faut pas créer
des problèmes aujourd'hui qu'on ne sera
pas résoudre demain alors moi oui
effectivement c'est la position qui me
semble la plus légitime
mais quand on y pense la modernité ça
c'est absolument pas basé sur cette
posture là la modernité c'est le
contraire c'est investir aujourd'hui en
espérant que ce soit rentable demain
c'est à voir fois avoir la croyance en
demain et croire que demain la tige à
sion l'intelligence humaine pourra
toujours résoudre les problèmes demain
qu'on a créé aujourd'hui
et en fait
la croyance des croissants mais c'est le
contraire c'est que demain on ne sera
pas forcément résoudre les problèmes
qu'on a créé aujourd'hui et pour ça il
ya un exemple mec s'appelle malthus il
ya deux cents ans qui était vraiment
dans cette posture qui a dit ouh la la
croissance démographique faut tout
arrêter parce que on est un milliard et
on ne saura jamais subvenir aux besoins
de plus d'un milliard de personnes
deux cents ans plus tard on s'aperçoit
bien qu'on est capable durablement de
subvenir aux besoins de plus d'un
milliard de personnes
surtout s'ils vivent comme en grande
bretagne à l'époque on est tout à fait
capable de faire ça et pour vous dire il
était dense tout croyant cela il s'est
trompé et alors moi je me dis
bah
pas pour quelle de scénario pour le cal
de sérieux je vais me battre si dans une
certaine mesure ils sont tous basés sur
une croyance
parce que
je suis pas historien mais je suis
encore moins de 20 donc si je me plante
je me dis que j'aurais l'air malin avec
morato là au milieu des vaisseaux qui
décolle dans tous les sens car elle est
mince qu'il aura finalement gérard
finalement il sera finalement parvenu à
faire de l'espèce humaine une espèce qui
a colonisé toutes les planètes
et je me si sk pas un truc à faire un
truc des valeurs des concepts a poussé
qui font que quel que soit le scénario
qui adviennent demain ça soit la
meilleure version de ce scénario qui
adviennent
parce que ces scénarios dont je vous
parle depuis tout à l'heure ils sont pas
monolithiques
c'est comme les ordinateurs il ya toute
une gamme de scénario et ça va du
scénario hyper dictatorial à un scénario
les 7 milliards d'individus sera ainsi
tous en rond et font de la gouvernance
partagée vous pouvez très bien avoir une
hyper croissance également répartie
entre tous et une décroissance ou il ya
deux personnes qui s'accaparent toutes
les richesses des autres
vous pouvez avoir l'exact inverse
donc la question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
peut pousser
pour que la version la plus conviviale
la plus humaine la meilleure de ceux de
n'importe lequel des scénarios advienne
et sur ça
il ya un philosophe français bertrand
qui a qui a trouvé et qui a parlé d'un
concept que moi je trouve hyper
intéressant il dit le supplément de
techniques à apporter à l'homme un
supplément de puissance et en fait pour
qu'on arrive vraiment à maîtriser ce
supplément de puissance
il faudrait qu'on ait un supplément
d'âme parce que c'est vrai - aujourd'hui
vous aujourd'hui on est infiniment plus
puissant que tous nos ancêtres ont peu
de communiquer à n'importe qui dans le
monde on peut en un clic
envoyer n'importe quelle information on
a axé la connaissent à la connaissance
au bout de nos smartphones on peut
consommer des produits du monde entier
on peut voyager vite et loin
sociétalement on est aussi plus puissant
que jamais on peut avoir un impact sur
l'environnement sur le climat sur la
biodiversité et si on a envie il ya un
mec qui peut détruire la planète entière
et en fait pour gérer toute cette
puissance que nous apporte la technique
on a le même outil de base un cerveau
d'homo sapiens standard le même cerveau
que nos ancêtres il ya deux cent mille
ans exactement le même il avait qu'à
regarder tranquillement en tribu dans
les plaines d'afrique est justement un
banc de tribus il ya un professeur le
professeur d'un bar qui s'est posé la
question de quoi dépend la taille des
tribus de primates
ça dépend de facteurs environnementaux
comme l'abondance de nourriture la
taille des arbres la grosseur des
grappes de bananes ou bien de facteurs
biologiques et génétiques
et en fait il a trouvé
qu'il ya une corrélation entre la taille
des tribus de primates et la taille du
néocortex en fait du rapport entre le
néocortex et le reste du cerveau bleu ce
rapport néocortex sur taille du cerveau
est grand plus le nombre d'individus
dans une tribu de primate est élevé ça
semble logique parce que comme le cortex
et le centre des fonctions cognitives
supérieures imprimable qui a de grosses
connu de grosses capacités cognitives
il est capable de gérer la complexité
d'un nombre important dans la tribu et
de ce rapport et de cette corrélation
confiseurs d'un bar a conclu que le
nombre optimal pour une tribu d'homo
sapiens nous des primates aussi et bien
c'est 150 et c'est ça qu'on a appelé le
nombre de dunbar
alors est ce qui est fascinant s'il ya
des études scientifiques qui montrent
encore aujourd'hui le nombre de dunbar
est toujours pertinent parce que dans
les réseaux sociaux c'est 150 c'est
aussi grosso modo le nombre
d'utilisateurs avec lesquels on a une
véritable interaction que ce soit sur
facebook ou sur twitter c'est aussi le
nombre maximum des tribus dans les jeux
de rôle en ligne multijoueur
et
et c'est ça qui est fou c'est que
50 ce nombre de dambach et b le but du
jeu c'est quelque part l'augmenter à 7
milliards
par cette limite delà de laquelle il est
hyper difficile de maintenir la cohésion
du groupe
en fait quand on y pense c'est hyper
logique parce que 150
ça nous permet dans un tribut d'avoir
des liens sociaux de l'empathie avec
n'importe lequel des membres de ce
groupe de ce groupe de la tribu parce
que c'est ça qui nous permet aussi de
réguler instinctivement notre rapport
aux autres parce que honnêtement c'est
un peu dur d'être injuste et de causer
du tort à quelqu'un quand cette personne
mais on sait qu'en lui cause du tort
parce qu'elle a en face
ensuite c'est un peu difficile parce
qu'on la connaît très bien et qu'en plus
elle habite l'attendent la tente d'en
face aux risques de la croiser à tout le
monde alors qu'au final si la personne
on n'a pas de conscience qu'on lui fait
du tort qu'en plus cette personne
on n'a même pas conscience qu'elles
existent et que ces personnes-là
rencontrera jamais parce que même si on
a conscience qu elle existe elle habite
à l'autre bout de la planète et c'est
beaucoup plus facile on y arrive tous et
à 150 ce qui se passe c'est que
l'empathie la proximité de tous envers
tous
c'est ça qui régule naturellement la vie
du groupe et en fait dans l'est une
tribu de 7 milliards et bien c'est
extrêmement difficile
le monde il est tellement complexe
aujourd'hui que c'est infiniment
difficile de savoir
toutes les conséquences que vont avoir
nos actions sur n'importe qui dans la
planète et ce qui se passe dans ce cas
là c'est que comment effectivement
ressentir de l'empathie pour les gens
qui par exemple fabrino chaussures qui
vivent à l'autre bout de la planète qui
ont des conditions de travail
déplorables qui travaillaient 14 heures
par jour tout ça pour nourrir leur
famille un petit peu plus à leur faim et
en fait dans ce dans le système actuel
c'est cette distance entre nos actions
et leurs impacts qui rend l'injustice du
monde possible
et du coup que faire mais en fait y'a 2
rien d'action le premier c'est avoir un
peu plus conscience des impacts qu'ont
nos actions et deuxièmement il faut que
ces actions
elle est une conséquence émotionnel
qu'elle nous créer de l'empathie pour
qu'on arrive à à gérer l'information de
ses impacts qu'on arrive à modifier
notre comportement en fonction de cette
empathie et pour ça il faut qu'on se
rapproche tous il faut qu'on ait tous la
sensation il y en a d'autres qui l'ont
dit aujourd'hui qu'on fait partie de la
même et unique tribu de 7 milliards
d'individus et en fait c'est peut-être
ça le supplément d'âme dont personne ne
parle et c'est cette conscience
cette connaissance des impacts qu'on a
dans le monde à laquelle s'ajouteraient
une émotion une empathie globale qui
nous parmi qui nous permettrait d'
arbitrer instinctivement en fait toute
cette connaissance est en fait c'est ça
que je me dis qu'il faut pousser et ça
quel que soit le scénario croissant ou
décroissant
c'est ce supplément d'âme là qu'il faut
pousser mais alors concrètement comment
faire pour être plus juste a plus
mais déjà il faut que en améliore notre
âme individuel pour ça je pense qu'il
faut que l'éducation le seul but de
l'éducation sa note est de faire en
sorte qu'on ait plus conscience de nos
impacts qu'on sache mieux quelle est
notre place dans le monde qu'on sache
qu'il ya un monde autour de nous qui
nous englobe et dont nous faisons partie
et ensuite il faut que cette confiance
cette reconnaissance elle débouche sur
des émotions de l'empathie globale et ça
le meilleur moyen honnêtement c'est de
se décentrer de regarder de l'extérieur
de s'extraire de notre perspective
nombriliste à laquelle on regarde le
monde d'être conscient qu'on fait partie
d'un tout qui nous englobe et moi la
pratique que je que j'essaie de faire
tout à l'heure dans les loges faisait
pareil c'est la méditation
lorsque la méditation c'est exactement
ça la méditation cents soit et on se
concentre sur un support n'importe
lequel notre respiration une mousse sur
le mur qu importe
et en fait on essaie de se regarder de
s'observer
de l'extérieur on regarde nos émotions
nous ressenti émerger dans notre
conscience et en fait quand on fait ça
quand on se met à distance qu on
s'observe de l'extérieur et quand nokia
ses émotions ses ressentis et bien ça
permet de mieux se comprendre et mieux
se comprendre c'est aussi mieux nous
comprendre et mieux nous comprendre
finalement ça nous rapproche des autres
de tous les autres et en fait je pense
qu'il faut voir la méditation comme ça
la méditation c'est peut-être un outil
qui va nous permettre de développer
l'empathie à une échelle rendu
nécessaire par la complexité du monde
actuel
en fait la médiation c'est tout
simplement une sorte de gym une gym du
néocortex et peut-être qu'à force de
pratiquer dans deux cent mille ans nos
enfants les enfants de nos enfants de
nos enfants de nos enfants de nos
enfants
ils auront peut-être néocortex affûté
comme une arbalète
alors oui je suis d'accord avec vous
esthétiquement il ya peut-être un petit
coup à jouer et ensuite
là
développer
une conscience globale parce qu'en fait
nous tous les 7 milliards il faut se
rendre compte qu'on constitue une
civilisation une société qui a une sorte
de super organisme et ce super organisme
il faut aussi qu'il est un néo cortex un
cerveau un supplément d'âme et pour ça
il faut qu'on crée tous toujours plus
d'outils de communication pour que
l'information arrive à circuler dans ce
cerveau global et ça ça fait un moment
qu'on y planche
on a inventé le langage après on a un
telle écriture l'imprimerie la radio la
télévision
on est même allé jusqu'à inventer
l'anglais il ya un mois on ne peut pas
faire plus d'efforts que ça
et vraiment il faut que cette
information est circulent et en fait je
me suis rendu compte et j'ai lu des
articles me font me rendre compte
qu'aujourd'hui on a un outil fantastique
pour que la que l'information circule et
cet outil c'est un outil décentralisée
un outil auquel quatre milliards
d'individus en accès à un outil qui
n'appartient à personne
un outil dont en fait qu' une sorte de
cerveau dont nous sommes tous quelque
part en europe par exemple ça
ça c'est la carte c'est une c'est la
carte en fait c'est des neurones
interconnectés et en fait
ça ressemble c'est magnifique et ça
ressemble de très près à ça et ça en
fait c'est une cartographie de toutes
les adresses ip connectées les unes avec
les autres et en fait quelque part je me
dis que internet
c'est exactement ça intéresse c'est
notre cerveau global c'est notre
meilleure chance d'avoir ce supplément
d'âme dont personne parle et c'est pour
ça que c'est hyper important d'avoir un
internet libre de l'internet où
l'information de qualité circule de
manière fluide c'est pour ça qu'un tracé
un lieu où on doit débattre où on doit
être en désaccord
on doit confronter nos différences et
pas du tout un internet où il ya des
îlots hermétique de penser c'est vrai
qu'il faut faire attention aux
intelligente intelligence artificielle
privé notamment qui nous propose du
contenu en permanence qu'on aime et qui
du coup va nous conforter dans notre
propre vision du monde est ce que
vraiment on veut laisser la circle line
la circulation de l'information dans le
cerveau global aux mains dans le pouvoir
d'une intelligence artificielle privé
c'est ça la question et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut qu'on se dote prendre non
seulement un internet libre
mais l'internet citoyen acteur parce qu
un internet libre et acteur c'est un
cerveau global un supplément d'âme
global libre et acteur
et en fait c'est vraiment ça dont je
voulais vous parler aujourd'hui que je
voulais vous dire c'est que cette quête
de l'hypercroissance de l'âne du
supplément d'âme qu'il nous manque cette
quête de l'hypercroissance d'une
conscience collective individuelle
cette quête d'une hyper croissance de la
sensation de faire partie d'une même et
seule tribu eh bien ça doit être ça
notre projet de société
ça doit être ça dans une nouvelle
définition du progrès et ce projet vers
lequel on doit attendre ce n'est ni la
croissance pour la croissance ni la
décroissance pour la décroissance mais
l'hypercroissance de l'âme de la société
humaine
et quand on voit arriver une invention
une innovation la seule question qu'on
doit se poser c'est est-ce que ça répond
à ce besoin d'hypercroissance de l'âme
de la société humaine et voilà pour
passer de 150 à 7 milliards pour faire
passer le nombre de dambach 255
milliards il nous faut absolument
veiller à ce que l'information circule
de manière libre dans notre cerveau
global mais il faut aussi veiller à
l'amélioration des deux cerveaux qui va
permettre qui vont permettre à toute
cette information d'être sublime et et
l'amour l'amélioration de ces deux
cerveaux que soit notre cerveau d'homo
sapiens ou notre cerveau global internet
dont nous sommes tous en europe eh bien
ça doit être ça le progrès et rien
d'autre merci
[Musique]